as the impeachment debate heats up in
Washington much of the country is
bracing for bitterly cold winter weather
road conditions are already dangerous in
parts of Texas due to ice and there are
winter storm advisories from New Mexico
to Ohio over the weekend people in all
but nine states could be affected by
winter weather chief weather caster
Lonnie Quinn of our New York station
wcbs-tv is here Lonnie what can we
expect well you know you were talking
about how much of the country is gonna
be affected take a look at the visual
I've got for you here I mean this is
this is how much really has to deal with
winter weather and I'm talking just ice
and snow the worst of it looks to be
probably around the Dakotas and tomorrow
blizzard warnings will go into effect
also you know eastern Kansas could see
some of the worst icing out there with a
quarter inch or more on everything so
driving nearly impossible now the other
side of this obviously if you have a
winter storm you need the cold air as
well so this morning we are starting off
with a feels like temperature in Duluth
at 10 below Montpelier Vermont feels
like 19 below Boston right now it feels
like two degrees above zero the story
there is Sunday of this week it was 74
in Boston wanna flip that is so here's
our storm right now we're looking at
snow around Omaha South that we have
that layer of icing as it makes it push
throughout this day sometime later
tonight it's gonna be making its push
into like the Chicago area Chicago's
funny the north side of Chicago you can
see a bit more snow than the south side
of Chicago I think gonna turn over very
quickly just some sleet and then rain
but really tonight we're looking
anywhere from Michigan over to Wisconsin
for snow and then it moves into the
Northeast as well but the snow totals
are not all that big for anybody I mean
it this is a real problem for you know
driving on the roadways and things but
take a look hardly anyone seeing a foot
of snow except as it gets to the east I
think the I think the tug Hill Plateau
in New York State this area you see
right there just north of Syracuse what
happens is you get the story you've got
the storm to deal with but also some
lake effect snow so that's where you
could pile up to a foot or more but uh
it's gonna be eventful and I think again
trying to drive or even flights will
have a problem with the storm this
weekend eventful is a nice word for it
Lonnie yeah we're trying to keep it you
know under control right you do that
thank you